bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france le conflit entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan dont le haut
karabagh et vieux d'une trentaine
d'années qu'est ce qui a mis le feu aux
poudres il ya maintenant dix jours et et
pensiez-vous au début de ces récents
événements que l'affrontement pourrait
prendre une telle tournure oui c'est pas
n'est pas étonnant quand on connaît
cette ce conflit qui n'est pas du tout
gelé
c'est un conflit qui rebondit il ya
pratiquement des morts tous les ans
depuis le cessez le feu en 1994 et on
sait que monsieur aliev le président
aliyev a toujours dit qu'il ne voyait
qu'une solution militaire à ce conflit
et il ya eu en juillet de cette année
juillet 2020 une escalade de moins
grande ampleur mais qui était déjà un
signe de que des choses se préparait
quelles pourraient être les conséquences
d'un conflit direct entre ces deux ex
républiques soviétiques du caucase
ça dépend ce que les uns et les autres
veulent faire si vous voulez le
l'azerbaïdjan n'a jamais reconnu la
sécession du nagorno karabagh et et
l'occupation des territoires qui sont
autour puisqu'on sait que les les forces
arméniennes ont occupé des raids des
districts qui étaient en dehors de la
région du karabagh depuis 1994 ça
représente à peu près presse pour cent
de l'ensemble du territoire de
l'azerbaïdjan et il voulait les re dont
il voulait récupérer labatut haine sur
ces territoires
ce que les forces arméniennes évidemment
ne veulent pas lui concédé il ya des
négociations qui ont été engagées il ya
eu diverses phases en 1997 on semblait
assez proche d'une solution
les arméniens s'engageant rendre tel ou
tel territoire et en cherchant une
solution pour le statut final de cette
région qui avait été donnée par staline
à la à l'azerbaïdjan
mais on en est resté là les dirigeants
politiques ont changé de part et d'autre
et est aujourd'hui on est dans cette
situation d'impasse total avec des
décors des armes lourdes et ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que
la turquie s'en est mêlé tout le monde
vend delà des armes aux belligérants
les russes ventes d armes et à
l'azerbaïdjan et à l'arménie avec un
léger avantage disons technologiques aux
forces arméniennes liste israël la
turquie vend des drones d'autres
l'azerbaïdjan donc on est dans une
région surarmés et et où les
azerbaïdjanais semble déterminé à
récupérer au moins une partie des
territoires occupés de façon à engager
peut-être des négociations à partir
d'une situation plus favorable à l'or
parmi les présents dans la région vous
évoquez à l'entente il ya donc la russie
l'iran et la turquie le chef de la
diplomatie turc se rendra dans la
journée en azerbaïdjan à quoi joue la
turquie dans le haut-karabagh on ne sait
pas exactement quels sont les buts de
monsieur erdogan parce que un de ses
plus fidèles associer le un parti turc
qui a représenté quand même 17 % des
voix aux dernières élections lui réclame
le changement des frontières de
l'arménie
c'est à dire qu'il réclame que on
procède in fine est un échange de
territoires qui verrait la turquie avoir
une frontière directe commune avec
l'azerbaïdjan
c'est un des vieux rêve des
nationalistes turcs et ça c'est
particulièrement inquiétant je dirais le
groupe de minsk qui regroupe on le
rappelle à les etats-unis la france et
la russie ne ne parvient pas ça entendre
ils réclament depuis plusieurs jours un
cessez-le-feu son succès ce que vous
direz que c'est le résultat de plusieurs
décennies d'une forme de désintérêt pour
ce conflit
je ne dirais pas que c'est du désintérêt
mais le les diplomaties occidentales et
au fond les russes n'ont pas fait
tellement d'autres choses
ils ont toujours caressé les deux
belligérants dans le sens du poil
c'est à dire que l'union européenne par
exemple a toujours dit à l'azerbaïdjan
nous soutenons le
la défense des des frontières
internationales donc vous avez la
tutelle sur le karabagh et ont dit aux
arméniens l'union européenne disait aux
arméniens nous soutenons évidemment le
principe de l'autodétermination des
peuples et donc les arméniens ont le
droit à avoir leur territoire dans ces
conditions on ne peut rien arriver à
rien parce que au fond on dit aux deux
ce qu'ils ont envie d'entendre
et ça n'avance pas alors on connaît les
relations houleuses entre la france et
la turquie ce qui risque évidemment de
compliquer toute tentative de médiation
française dans ce conflit est-ce que
alors c'est à la russie de se poser en
médiatrice
écoutez je l'espère j'espère que moscou
peuvent effectivement faire quelque
chose je constate cependant que moscou
qui a des bonnes relations et avec
l'azerbaïdjan et encore plus avec
l'arménie parce que quand même avec
l'arménie il ya un traité de coopération
dans le cadre de la de l'organisation de
sécurité
mais jusqu'à présent moscou n'a jamais
pu faire en sorte qu effectivement des
pas concrets soient faits dans le sens
d'une négociation et dans le sens d'une
solution politique
mais pour que c'est pas concret et lieu
il faut que dans les deux pays
on prépare les opinions publiques à des
concessions parce que si on veut qu'ils
aient une vraie négociation avec deux
des étapes de solution du conflit il
faut que dans les deux pays
on dise aux gens
soyez prêts à des compromis pour
l'instant ça n'a jamais été fait merci
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions jean rabanne et je rappelle
que vous êtes un géographe spécialiste
du caucase et professeur à l'inalco